visit expressvpn.com yang and get three
extra months of expressvpn for free
[Music]
you've launched a small business
learning center for anyone trying to
start a small business
uh that you're trying to help the reason
i launched the learning center is that
one of the things that i learned through
my eight-year
journey with over a hundred businesses
on the air
is that there's a common thread of what
they were missing and they were missing
a depth of education
and the education isn't one plus one
equals two or what's the capital of the
state of florida
it's what are the real things that
happen in a business from inventory
management to hr risk to you know
hundreds and hundreds of topics and you
know that as a business owner
that those things happen and so i wanted
to create a center
where people felt hey it's free uh b
people could do it in the privacy of
their own home and there are so many
folks who don't know the answer to
things but they're embarrassed to admit
they don't know it
um and i i'm one of those people
sometimes if you ask me a question i may
fake it
and i decided years ago that i wasn't
going to fake it i was going to say
can you explain that to me i don't know
it i don't understand that
and i realize that the key is it's very
powerful if you can acknowledge
ignorance it's very powerful
it's it makes the other person feel uh
i think more connected to you yeah
[Music]
all right on today's episode of yang
speaks
andrew and i talk about the coronavirus
relief bill that's on the floor in
congress
and talk about what is going to happen
if we do have a vaccine
and what this means to the american
people specifically you
we also have the one and only marcus
lemonis one of the coolest entrepreneurs
in the game you don't want to miss this
episode check it out
[Music]
and we are back from georgia yes zach is
in georgia too
because zach and i are attached at the
hip
anywhere he goes i go when zach goes on
vacation
i go to i say to evelyn hey baby
zach's going to come on vacation can i
go
no that's not really the way it goes um
because zach is still
unmarried so i guess if one of us is
going to
dictate where we're going he might be
the guy with the
the wife and kids uh so we are here in
georgia it's a blast
i'm going to be campaigning with the
legend martin luther king the third
uh today when i say campaigning i'll
actually be knocking on doors how fun is
that
by the time this podcast gets aired you
probably
can find that stuff on social media
knocking on doors has been fun
um you have like real honest exchanges
with folks
some folks recognize me some folks don't
um
even if they don't recognize me i i cut
sort of an odd figure i'm sure
[Laughter]
do they what's been the reaction when
you knock on the door you know like i
think
you know there's fox news it's the
reaction any of us would have zach
the reaction is who the [ __ ] is knocking
on my door that's like that's the
reaction moment everyone
wow you know because no because we're
unfortunate we're not in a state of
american life it's like oh my neighbor
is knocking like it's not really the way
it's going down
it's like i don't know about the rest of
you someone knocks on your door you're
like
what the heck's going on like who is it
like there's like this alarmed feeling
you have
am i the only one who has that does that
say something about me no i do oh my dog
usually goes nuts too
um so it's never
yeah yeah so there's some trepidation as
they approach
and then when they see me they're
they their curiosity is peaked they're
like well this is
um not what i'd expected and like what
is this about and then
very very quickly i uh talk about being
there
canvassing for uh democratic
candidates jon ossoff and reverend
warnock and and then they're like oh
i i know what this is this is like uh
like a political canvassing thing they
want me to vote oh
i'll definitely tell them i'm registered
to vote um you know
but i will say that there's something
very very
powerful where there is like an
activation
exchange that happens where
if they are registered and they know
about the election then they
uh confirm and get very excited and you
really feel like the odds of them
voting have increased significantly uh
in that instance because like maybe
they'll be like yeah like i know about
it but now i'm like oh i should really
do it like
it is very uh reinforcing
and then if they don't know much about
it then you feel like they definitely
know about it now and like you gave
gave them a sense of it um so it does
feel like canvassing
works and the data bears that out
what um i've seen this but i'm i think a
lot of our listeners probably haven't
what's been your georgia pitch you know
yang gets on the stump
he's got to take his message for joe and
kamala
that was originally the original message
for andrew that went to joan kamala and
now has gone to
to ossoff and warnock and georgia what's
what's the stump
right now have you tied in you know what
message are you are you driving home
i say people need help people need
relief
and electing john ossoff and reverend
warnock
is the fastest way to speed that relief
up
and get it out
the doors of congress also address
things like health care that people care
deeply about
and the fun thing too is that when i
have these lists from
um the campaigns they are registered
democrats they don't send you to
uh knock on mega household doors or
anything like that so
so it is like it's a very fairly
straightforward
uh pitch when you're knocking on doors
it's like hey get out and vote
uh if uh if i was giving a speech to a
general audience that was
um more mixed then it would be about
trying to have a functional government
as opposed to a dysfunctional government
because that's what's at stake
got it speaking of functional
government we have a relief bill
kind of we have a proposed relief bill
and i'm pissed and you're pissed
because it doesn't really have
any direct cash relief it does have an
increase
and i credit some of humanity forwards
work to this it's like there is an
increase to
unemployment um it's like 300 a week
which is not which is not nothing
it's like 12 a month um but
you have to file all the paperwork uh it
it's yeah it's ambiguous
yeah um so thoughts on the relief bill
give us an overview what you've seen
coming out of
or not coming out of congress right now
you know this process is very deeply
telling
zack where you had mitch mcconnell
saying
no no no uh you know 400 million
nancy pelosi saying yes yes yes 2
trillion
and then they could not come together 4
months
the white house at one point was ready
to sign off on a 1.8 trillion dollar
deal
uh and i was like take that deal let's
try to get better than that
uh and then and then they didn't take
that deal
um and now what happened was
a group of relatively centrist
uh senators from both parties it's like
mitt romney joe manchin susan collins
got together and said hey we're sick of
the gridlock and so we are going to
split the baby in half
900 billion dollars uh and this is the
thing that
is infuriating to me is that now
everyone's like
oh yeah okay yeah we we should do that
we should do that and i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
that like uh that you just like had your
position staked out all this time and
then as soon as someone comes up with
like a
like who could not think that
splitting the difference between two
trillion dollars and 500 billion
like you know it's like someone
magically said like hey you know what's
kind of between those numbers
900 billion and then was like oh well
thank you for
enlightening us like what it's it's
ridiculous that it took
a group of bipartisan senators proposing
something that's relatively obvious
that is kind of like a split the
difference type proposal
and then now things have fallen so
deeply in the calendar
that nancy pelosi and the gang and
others are like yeah yeah we're gonna
get on board with this let's try and
push this through
because they should have pushed
something through months and months ago
it did not take
until december with this bipartisan
group
shaming them essentially being like hey
guys like it is ridiculous that you
can't do the obvious and negotiate and
come to the middle
so here we're going to present a middle
ground alternative so
big picture it's an indictment of the
process
i applaud the senators who stepped up
and proposed this because
it like at least eventually someone was
like this is total [ __ ] like you
know
we should uh try and come in the middle
i wish that
the proposal was much much more cash
oriented than it is
um but i but i'm not some
um some person who's like look like i've
been saying
for months in some way or another
something is better than nothing
so if you pass something i give you like
the thank goodness you did something and
like you said zach
those unemployment insurance uh benefits
of 300
a week would be immensely meaningful for
millions of americans so if you do that
i support it i applaud it but
it should not have taken this long if
you're going to do it you should skew it
much more towards cash relief because
now when i did the math the 900 billion
dollars you're
looking at is almost three thousand
dollars ahead
for everyone and so if you were to line
up americans and say hey we've got this
900 billion dollar plan
it's like a couple hundred billion to
state and local governments which i
support
uh it's got
some more ppp money which i support
though it's inefficient
uh you know um so we've got these things
uh on unemployment insurance benefits or
everyone gets 3k uh you know 80 percent
of americans would be like
when just give everyone 3k that helps
the small business owner that helps
small business owners customers that
helps the state and local employees that
helps the person who doesn't have a job
that person that that helps like the the
folks that
are going to slip through the cracks
from the institutional
um plumbing because if you plow hundreds
of billions of dollars into
state and local governments which again
i support like
uh you know there are going to be a lot
of people that never see a dime of that
so if you're trying to take care of
people just take care of people
and then let the institutions um kind of
adapt and figure it out because if
everyone who touched the institution is
taken care of
like the most blatant example of this is
airlines it's like you have airlines
they're hemorrhaging money
i get it it's terrible um they're firing
a lot of people
terrible it's like like when you tell me
about an airline who do i care about
the airline attendants the the
the flight attendants the people who
throw the the luggage
onto the the plane um you know the
pilots to a lesser extent
um i say a lesser extent because they're
you know like
they have savings um unlike a lot of
these other people
uh uh so if you just say look we're
gonna take care of all of the human
beings that work at the airline
uh and then like i don't care about the
capital structure of the airline
like i don't care about you know whether
they have to
like you know we have systems for that
like they they can go into
some sort of um you know receivership or
like you know
financial distress and continue to
operate businesses do that all the
freaking
they have assets like the people you
know they go bankrupt
people will still there's still money
there's still business there's still
revenue line there's still planes they
can sell whatever it is like so many
human beings they go bankrupt they got
nothing
right yeah we're taking care of
institutions not people is a big
complaint
it's like you know if you say look the
airline's balance sheet is okay but like
all the people
you know and they fired 90 000 people
anyway last i checked you know what i
mean
so it's like you true up there you true
up their balance sheet
and then they're just like hey now that
i've got the money i still don't need
these freaking you know
like uh landlocked um
airline attendants and luggage uh
packers and and uh security people on
the rest of it
um so so that stuff makes me very very
sad
you can tell i'm frustrated uh and the
fact that we're in december and people
are doing
again the obvious it's like you know you
know there was part of me that was like
you know if you come up with something
magical then i'll be like okay but like
you knew
you know and said they just come up with
like a hybrid um
a hybrid of the obvious super excited
for anything that gets money out into
the american people's hands like i'll
applaud but there's a lot of frustration
i know i'm not the only one who feels it
because like you watch this process
i know you're you're like are you
[ __ ] kidding me like you guys can't
get anything done since march and april
and then
like you eventually come together with
like the most obvious thing in the world
which is a compromise package
that doesn't even have cash relief the
one thing that would work
[Music]
it's the holidays it's time to reach out
to all those people that you haven't
thought about all year
bust out that bust out that holiday list
say wait a minute
what's your address i'm actually getting
a lot of messages saying what's your
address which i appreciate thank you
everyone i should not make light of this
and then after you get all of these
beautiful cards with that one photo
of you and your family you're proud of
what do you need
some stamps it's time to mail that stuff
and do you really want to go to the post
office and figure it all out when you
can
be 21st century smart and use stamps.com
it brings the u.s postal service and ups
right to your computer
any letter any package any class of mail
if you're not sending cards and you're
sending a giant boom box as a gift
uh you can do that too it doesn't matter
they'll even send you
a freaking free scale if you sign up for
stamps.com so don't spend a minute at
the post office this year who would want
to go to the post office
during a pandemic that would be unwise
during the holidays
during the holidays truly unwise so
there's no risk
with my promo code yang you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus
free postage and a digital scale is it
big enough
for you to weigh yourself on it there's
only one way to find out and that's to
actually get it
no long-term commitments or contracts
it's actually not you can't weigh a
human on it
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in yang
that's stamps.com enter yang stamps.com
never go to the post office again hey
andrew what are what are you and evelyn
getting me for christmas
are you getting me something that you're
gonna use you can put stamps on
uh you know i'm i'm getting uh i'm i'm
giving you
the greatest gift of all zack in that
zoom companion
your time you can't put a stamp on that
you but you could put a stamps.com ad on
that yes you can so stamps.com enter
yang
and pour one out for zach's ego here is
he's clearly not getting a present from
the yang's for christmas um and if i'm
not getting president
i don't know i don't know who is andrew
i give up all right love you guys
stamps.com enter yang
let me ask you this like you know i've
been
you've met a lot of these people i've
met a lot of these people
these people being congressmen and women
senators
representatives is it that they don't
care is it that they don't understand
is it that there's no consequences for
no for their inaction
is it that they're in a bubble like what
like to me
every american is like yeah do something
bro like that that is like the natural
reaction of americans
um but what why what's the why here why
is that why is this an
action happening let's say magically you
are a member of congress right now zach
you're one of like the you know 435
you would get there and you would find
that you have almost zero influence
over this negotiation uh if i make you
like an
ordinary congress person or junior
congress congressperson um you have
party leadership
with nancy pelosi and city hoyer in the
gang
you know they're 78 80 years old uh
and they're like settle down zach you're
still in your 30s like
you know we you haven't been around the
block like we have um
let leadership handle this uh and you
really don't have much of a choice
there are dozens of members of congress
that are and i mean you know what are
your choices really
so that dynamics happening in the house
with nancy pelosi
uh where she's essentially dictating
you know negotiation and you're not in
the room like you can't suggest
something
like you even propose a secret bill to
mcconnell
i don't know if you saw this there was a
separate bill that her and schumer did
alone
anyway keep going yeah yeah so that
they're exactly that that just says it
all it's like literally like nancy and
chuck schumer are like you know so so
like what happens is a lot of the
ordinary legislators are good people
they got elected they're trying to
uh stick up for their constituents but
they don't have really any say in this
um you know majority party you know the
leadership has it tied up minority party
it's even worse
and congressional legislative rules have
really become very dark
where there's something called the
hastert rule that uh we're not going to
hear a bill unless the majority of the
majority party
wants wants it so if you think about it
that means that
like no one can introduce a bill
unless you're like if you're in the
minority you're like this is all a giant
waste of my time
um but but the the tough part is
if a constituent or a you know reporter
sticks a mic in your face and is like
hey what can you do about this like you
can't just be like i can do absolutely
nothing about this
like in instead you say oh you know oh
like you know i'm going to continue to
fight for like the principles that my
constituents put me in like you have no
there's not nothing you can really do
um and and so that's what's happening
zach is you have
really like a few human beings who are
very very distant
from everyday reality uh in the form of
um the the leadership
uh i i believe the end and in the rank
and file have very little control
so then the the rank and file some of
them have come up and tried to
present um compromise
alternatives there was like the problem
solvers caucus that proposed a bill
that's actually not that
different from this one like
like a group of of members got together
uh and said hey we're sick of the
gridlock
um you know here's our compromise bill
and unfortunately it did not take off
um and the reason why this is different
uh i think one is the senate not the
house this time um
two it's december uh three nancy has a
tighter grip on
um the house than mitch has on the
senate so if a group of senators come
together and propose it then everyone's
like oh i guess
we you know we should really look at
that um
so that so that's what's going on is
that uh like if there's something you
really need to dig into and we talked
about this in earlier podcasts with
kathryn gale
uh it's it's the mechanics of how things
happen in the house
uh you know people don't realize just
how jacked up it is in there
yeah it's um and then to top it all off
you've got a lame duck president right
you have a
yeah you have a checked out like him
executive who's you know i'm not reeling
about
that i i you know he i mean he's he
seems to be in
um even worse mental shape than usual uh
he's gonna be coming here to georgia in
a minute
and people are kind of chewing their
fingernails being like oh man he's going
to be so off the rails
anyway that's happening this weekend
it'll have happened by the time this
airs
yeah trump trump rally in georgia um
oh boy um so
i think it's one of the reasons why um
we are doing what we're doing humanity
forward um because cash relief needs to
be
we need to hammer congress with um the
why on cash relief so if you haven't
donated move humanityforward.com
we are spending money on education
polling and advertisements and research
and lobbying and all the stuff like
behind the scenes that needs to happen
to get
cash relief done and if we don't do
anything clearly you know the result
i i've had very very encouraging
conversations with members of congress
it's very exciting like we have enough
congressional support where
uh at least out of the house uh like we
we could get together and have like uh
you know like a proposal for sure um so
the
the plan is to try and just jit up
support to get it to a point where
uh it will get real momentum and uh and
pass uh so that's what we're working on
if that sounds good to you please do
donate to movehumanityforward.com
it's exciting uh you know like i feel
like it's the highest leverage thing
i may ever do because it's like you know
we have a chance to unlock
hundreds of billions of dollars for
people uh the money's going out we just
need to
change the ratio of the amount going to
people
as opposed to institutions correct so
factually speaking um corona it's got
good news and bad news um
sorry the bad news coronavirus is
getting worse right now so hop
civilizations doubled
totalizing the month of november we had
about 51 deaths an hour
according to a number of sources but
cnn's the one i used um
and then you had about 30 just shy of 37
000 deaths in november
um compared to and for context the flu
kills
22 000 americans uh a season
at least last year it did um so like
it's it's bad um but the good news
is that it looks like we have a vaccine
it's coming
there's a multiple vaccines and one of
the things i'm curious about andrew um
who cares about your thoughts on the
virus right now what's happening but
also
so former presidents i think this is
fascinating kind of hilarious uh
former presidents clinton bush and obama
have agreed to take the vaccine on tv to
promote
trust which i think is hilarious because
they kind of embody
what most americans don't trust which is
politicians
um but i'm curious your thoughts on
i love i love it uh you know i i had a
conversation with
um someone about this i would get the
vaccine on tv
uh and i'm in a lower risk profile than
those guys
i mean uh like the older ex-presidents
you know it's legit on both sides i mean
you know they're higher risk
but they're also you know probably going
to be made more uncomfortable by the
vaccine
so if you see they're exactly the right
demo like if you see a couple of elderly
gentlemen getting the vaccine
and you're an elderly american you're
like oh i should probably do that then
um so i i love it uh
yeah and and for black people
uh there's like a high mistrust of
vaccines for historical reasons and so
barack obama getting it on tv may help
with that
um so i'm a huge fan they need an asian
on that stage i'll go
[Laughter]
i guess like my hesitation is like the
people that
i i do think it's a good idea like
generally i just think a lot of
there's such a mistrust with our
government and politicians in general
which is why trump is elected why it's a
strong support
you know what people will mistrust that
they'll mistrust whether that actually
happened they're like oh they're
injecting salt water in them
like that's the way it's gonna go
uh that's actually i mean right there
it's gonna be fake news around it i mean
i
i think if you were president
um i think having former presidents do
it but also like being the president
doing it but also i think getting
you know i'd be curious of getting like
figures like a like your joe rogan or
tucker carlson or some of these or
athletes like um
yeah like we get everyone under the sun
we would just be like hey
it's your um uh
it's your patriotic duty to publicly
vaccinate uh specifically and then like
put that out on social media
um i you know that we have to try and
distribute the vaccine as quickly as
possible because people are dying
and it may not be you that's dying but
you may infect someone else who dies
uh so uh so i'll sign me up to take the
vaccine for sure
yeah i'm uh like i'm
i'm honest but honestly i'm a little
skeptical of it i'm like
uh because i'm healthy right i think
there's that inflation it's like well i
haven't
got corona i don't maybe i'm immune but
i do think there's a patriotic piece of
it to me i want to see
like they've published some studies i
think when they start pumping the
vaccine to people
they'll make all that available that
data really easily yeah yeah you need a
scientific consensus
of like folks that are unimpeachable to
be like look this thing is safe
and that that's what you're getting and
um um
that step needs to be taken for sure
yeah and a lot of scientists have said
this isn't a complicated virus like
they've known about it they just didn't
have a cure right they have to figure
out but it's not like uh
it's not hiv it took me you know it's
that it's
in terms of its complexity and its
ability to evolve and things like that
so
um i am optimistic and we'll be you know
talking about how we're taking the
vaccine
sure um but anyway i was just curious
your thoughts on
the trust piece of this you know oh the
trust thing is going to be ongoing we're
going to come back to this too
you know i came i was on the record
saying we should pay people to get the
vaccine
because that would increase adoption we
should be
investing billions and billions of
dollars to try and
both accelerate and increase adoption
levels
because people are dying and
you know and there are all of these
other uh effects in addition to the
the health effects uh the sickness and
the death
um so as soon as the vaccine's safe
we we need to invest in it we need to
say look i get it you don't trust it
uh you know what can we do to convince
you
uh just to smooth the path here's a
thousand bucks you know
the rest of it i mean realistically too
it's like if i
if i get a vaccine as an adult um what's
what's really like my downside or risk
my downside is that i'm gonna feel
crummy for a few days
that's really it uh you know so uh what
about long-term effects
like i don't know things we haven't been
able to study because we did objectively
rush it
to market well i'll tell you one thing
for sure that taking the vaccine
is going to have a much much lower like
um
you know like impact than if i actually
got
got the viruses walking around
and my getting the chronovirus
itself is an inevitability if i just
walk around forever not vaccinated
you know what i mean um one of our tight
ends on the bills tommy sweeney
uh got a he has midocarditis
i don't know what that is but it's a
heart condition that is a side effect of
coronavirus he had
he's out for the season um he had to
like basically take the year off after
that and he was perfectly the virus
itself
is nasty it's one reason why getting
this vaccine is the move
yeah if you wanna i trust in science
trust in science seriously
and trust anybody who says they had it
like a lot of people seriously got it
it's horrible
yeah um all right so we've got a cool
guest uh because this guy hosted one of
my favorite shows
called the prophet and i feel like i
don't know sometimes
when you can watch entertainment and
feel like you're learning something i
always feel like i did learn a lot from
this show
uh to me it's a win-win that's kind of a
nerd but um
let's talk about your your new bff on
the show
so you know on yang speaks we love
entrepreneurs and we've got
one of the most badass entrepreneurs in
the country
here on yang speaks this week it's
marcus lemonis you may know him from
cnbc's
the prophet uh which is the profit
but he goes around helping struggling
businesses and investing in them
and then he has another show the partner
where he then tries to find someone to
help him
operate the businesses that he's
invested in and this guy
has invested 75 million dollars of his
own money in dozens
of struggling businesses around the
country
and taking a loss on a lot of it he just
loves this
[ __ ] uh and it's
wild talking to someone who's wired that
deeply
uh for entrepreneurship i loved
uh what makes him tick uh you know
he and i i think i had some
some um fundamental beliefs in common
other things we
saw somewhat differently so thrilled to
have him
on the pod marcus lemonis
[Music]
okay we've all been doing a lot of
netflixing uh and one thing that i
have never have no idea how to keep
track of really is that apparently like
international netflix has all this stuff
that um
american netflix and then it all just
kind of moves around it's like the
content like hopscotch is
everywhere so like die hard will be on
netflix one day and then now
apparently it's only on south korean
netflix and so if you've got a hankering
for
content that you're not seeing right now
on your netflix
one kind of hip way to get there is to
use a vpn and just beam into the
internet like you're someplace else
and you get to keep your data safe no
one can see what you're doing
it's the approach that companies use to
protect employees privacy
and doesn't your privacy matter too so
expressvpn
not only can secure your data make it so
that your data is not getting sold and
resold but it can also give you access
to
all the content in the world because you
can beam in and sign in to these
services
from anywhere if that sounds interesting
to you for the holidays if you just
can't get enough
of some of the holiday movies that
you've been missing out on maybe you
miss i mean die hard is a holiday movie
am i right am i right
you go to expressvpn.com get an extra 3
months of expressvpn for free
watch what you want get your holiday fix
at expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am thrilled to welcome to the podcast
marcus lamonis you may know him as the
star and host of the prophet on cnbc
uh people in the public markets know him
as the ceo and chairman of camping world
which is like the biggest
rv company in the markets he's an
entrepreneur's
entrepreneur someone who's a huge
believer in
entrepreneurship as a force for good in
the world marcus is a thrill to have you
here welcome
andrew thank you you know i was looking
forward to this because you and i had
a little back and forth on twitter we
were i was telling people that you and i
were going to debate it on your podcast
and people were excited i don't even
know if you saw it
i did remember the original back and
forth and you and i were connected in
part
through dominique wilkins who's on the
board of this great non-profit
culture city that helps
families who are struggling with autism
in different ways inclusion services
so thank you for that absolutely 100 so
what are we meant to debate
i thought you and i agreed on everything
marcus
what was the twitter beef we we was not
a beef i don't i don't i don't
live my life that way neither do you but
i think it was around
um the difference between capitalism and
socialism
wow and so um uh where were you and
where was i
well i think i think rather than us
having revisionist history
uh you know i'm a super fan of yours and
the way you think about things be
primarily because you put people first
in all cases
uh and i think that this this dilemma
that we've lived in the last couple of
years
has really polarized people to think
about things
and feel the need to pick a side which
is why i wanted to start out by making
this comment about
back and forth i think there's a way to
pick a side
and have it be respectful like you are
and i'm always going to be and there's a
way to have differing opinions
and meet somewhere in the middle and so
part of the reason that i made that
mention when we first started
was to demonstrate for people how easy
it is to have good open dialogue
intelligent
friendly constructive dialogue that
doesn't have to be vicious and it
doesn't have to be
um anything other than exploring and
learning and listening
you know it's been it's important i've
always do that well i notice that you do
that
well thank you i felt like you and i
have a lot in common we're about the
same age
uh we're we're entrepreneurs um first
generation board in this country
um you had an advantage i did not have
which is you kind of grew up in a family
business
uh you know yeah like your your family
was
uh in the auto business and i have to
say like i think if you were like
uh anywhere near a car dealership it's
like one of the most genuine forms of
commerce that there is
you know like the other people that are
like in in business
uh but but i mean you worked at a car
dealership at a young age is that right
i did you know i my family had been in
the auto business for a number of years
and you say that i had
just an advantage by being in the
business and to some degree
i did but i will tell you andrew that
understanding how family businesses
function is part of the reason why i got
involved in small business because of
the dysfunction
that that exists in a family business
and
you know a lot of people don't like to
talk about it um
but you're right commerce is best in the
auto business because it truly is a
capitalistic environment
well i i have friends who grew up um
around family business as well and a lot
of them are very entrepreneurial
like i think if you're exposed to that
it's so real
and impactful and then if you go to
school and you get like a genuine uh you
know a
customary office job you're a little bit
like
bored honestly like i i think
you know and and for you you had a ton
of
uh energy and entrepreneurship uh from
day one
you you even made a political foray
relatively early on
which i appreciated because that's very
uh that's like a very big
uh big challenge at a young age
you know it's funny i as a kid i was
always involved in business
and i wanted to to really test the
boundaries of both myself
but i think at the time i was 20 or 21 i
wanted to test the boundaries of my
family
my family were huge republicans uh as a
as
as they were in miami and i went to
school in milwaukee and i worked for
senator herb cole
uh for a couple of summers and you know
when you're young you have an illusion
of things
uh that may be different than reality
but i was very much rooted in
social justice i think people sometimes
confuse
socialism with social justice
and i am a capitalist at heart i believe
in making money
but i do not believe it making money uh
at the cost of somebody else and so i
always tell people that say i want to
start a business so i can do good for
other people i'd say yeah
how about start a business run your
business run it really profitably
take the proceeds profits and the fruits
of that business
and then do good with it and i think
those two have to really be separated
out
and um when i ran for office i ran
in south florida in miami and to show
you what a neophyte i was
i ran against a two-term incumbent
cuban-american
and part of my area was miami beach and
i ran as a democrat part of my area was
miami beach
and part of my area was little havana
and i was always confused by the fact
that little havana
was a very very staunch republican
uh foothold and i didn't understand it
you know when you're 21 years old and
you're coming out of college
you tend not to do the necessary
research before you jump into things you
just sort of jump into them and hope
they work out
and i remember going to a few debates
and my family's business was
in little havana so i said okay i'm
going to run as a democrat
i have miami beach i have little havana
where everybody knows my family
and i ran into a bus saw and i learned
very quickly that
um that immigration and opportunity
don't always correlate to political
affiliation i made that mistake and
uh it was an interesting process i ended
up losing
by a pretty considerable amount i think
i ended up losing by like
six or seven points um and
it was a great experience for me because
i watched the two-term incumbent do
nothing
and i watch myself for about six months
knock on every door
raise money all the things that you know
you know are necessary to make it work
um and after i the night that i lost
i really matured through the process of
the night that i lost i cried like a
baby
because it was you know well it wasn't
because i
lost it was because i had never really
experienced
uh defeat that way and it was in a
public forum
and it was my first foray into at the
time when you're 21 it feels like
embarrassment right
but it wasn't yeah and it was the first
time that publicly it didn't work out
for me and uh
it was a real real strong building block
for the future real strong building
block for me
yeah i had a similar public failure when
i had a company go bust when i was 25
and so it wasn't as public as you and
that like you know no one picked up a
newspaper and read about it
um but everyone i knew knew about it and
that setback really really hurt like i
felt like a total failure
felt like everyone regarded me as a
failure
and that did end up building resilience
in the years afterwards because i was
like well like whatever i go through it
can't be as bad as that
you learned a lot about yourself i would
assume you learned a lot about yourself
oh yeah i learned a ton about myself uh
and
you know i got back on the horse a
number of years later where i ran a
private company
that did well another one did not do
well and then the one after that did
well
so i can relate to what you're saying
about
um about running a
quality business intrinsically like you
know it's like you
you want to be a good person you want to
treat people well and if the business is
successful
then you end up creating opportunities
for the folks who work for you
in a really profound and beautiful way
like i came of age
as a ceo of a small private company
and you feel like you're the head of an
extended family you know if you hire
someone you feel very responsible for
them and then if if they
prosper and you know can get married and
buy a home like
you know you you feel great about that
uh and then if tough times hit like you
look around and think like wow am i
really going to have to
you know let someone go or or make
cutbacks in various ways
so i think that maturation process for
me it coincided in my case with when i
met my now wife
and got married whereas for you you had
this like incredible
business growth path for for you know it
seems like your 20s and 30s
and then eventually you made the foray
into media and i'm really curious about
how the heck they found you where you
found them
because you are a natural in terms of
the media but there are a lot of ceos a
lot of chairmans like what how the heck
do they find you and say hey do you want
to go
identify small businesses and help them
out
it really came out of so my company's
only been public since 2016
and i've been making the profit since
2013 and i remember when i had my first
meeting
uh at um 30 rock at
nbc in downtown new york manhattan
and i walked into the building and i was
gosh i don't know i was in my
my 30s at the time and i was totally
overwhelmed by you know you go in there
and the saturday night live studios are
there and you
you go in for this pitch meeting with
you know a senior executive at nbc
and i i rarely get nervous but for the
first time i was nervous
and the meeting had been set up by
charlie ebersole the son of dick ebersol
who was in charge of nbc sports for
years
and i went into this giant conference
room with chairman of
cnbc mark hoffman and one of his
teammates jim ackerman
and uh the meeting had been set up and
they said okay we'd love to hear
what you have to say and i started the
meeting by telling them
that i did not think that they were
running the network properly
which is never really a good way to
start a meeting with a guy who runs the
place that you just said wasn't run
white and he said to me
well what do you mean by that and i said
you know you spend the bulk of your day
focusing on fortune 100 fortune 50
companies the public market the bond
market
uh the high yield market and at the end
of the day all those businesses started
as something else
2008 9 happens and all everybody's
talking about is the crash of the market
not the crash of the entrepreneur
and as the market starts to pick back up
again in 12 and 13
all we kept hearing about was the
rebound in the market not the crash
of the small business owner so i really
decided in that moment
to be very transparent and say listen i
think cnbc
doesn't understand its funnel and the
funnel to grow your
daytime business is to find viewers that
are going to want to be attracted to
business
in an unorthodox way and they're going
to want to be
uh feel like what the message you're
communicating to them is relatable
when you talk about a company making 4.2
billion dollars for the quarter
the guy who owns the flower shop or the
restaurant owner or whoever it may be
those numbers and those figures are
there they're fun to listen to
but you don't even know how many commas
or decimal points are in that equation
and so i pitched them on this idea of
really traveling the country
and trying to find unique stories of
great special business owners
that were story rich with business as
the backdrop
as opposed to business rich with the
story of the characters the families
being sort of a small tentacle of it and
i remember
um uh them saying to me well how's it
gonna work who's gonna
invest the money and ultimately and
you're like
i'm gonna do it you could keep your
money at bc
no well i said i was gonna go
it ended up being all my money andrew
for one specific reason i wanted to make
sure
that the process was authentic and i
wanted to make sure that the small
business owner
truly found um a partner
and not a producer and that's very hard
in television as you know it's
very hard to kind of find very rare in
fact
yeah it's it's very rare would require
someone like you who just loves small
business loves enterprise and
would actually want to put your money up
very rare no wonder it had to be you
marcus my gosh
because most people who'd want to do
this would be happy with the media
exposure but wouldn't want the
commitment because you know you get into
one of these businesses it's a massive
commitment
well in the in the eight years we've
been on there i've invested
over 75 million dollars
incredible and and in most cases
uh it doesn't work out i think wow
to be transparent about it in most cases
it doesn't work out and the odds are
people always want to keep score does it
work does it not work
and the odds are is that when you're
investing in a small business it by
nature has high risk
just like a restaurant has high risk or
a gym has high risk
that by nature has high risk and so the
investment thesis is relatively flawed
and my thesis was is if i can invest in
these folks
and create a social experiment and
create a curriculum for young people
that in the end in my overall enterprise
all the bigger businesses that i'm
either running or investing in
the front of that labor will sort of
manifest themselves and i'll get paid
dividends
in other ways that's an incredible
mindset of abundance
in action that's like look like if i
plant these seeds like it you know it'll
end up
uh flourishing in unprecedented and
unpredictable ways
that will end up impacting me
[Music]
you remember the beginning of the
pandemic uh when we were all like
what's this deal with toilet paper like
what do i have to do why do i have to
stock up on it
well one innovation that has hit the
market during this time
actually alleviates the need to cut
toilet paper by 80 percent
what is this magical device it's
something that some of you have been
abroad
know all about it's a bidet but now
because
we're modern you don't need to buy a new
appliance
you can just have a bidet attachment
that you can attach to an existing
toilet no electricity
nothing and then you can skip the toilet
paper
oh my gosh you can become
environmentally friendly
modern international sophisticated you
can start using
a french accent or whatever you want
this thing must be french
in its origin because it's called a
bidet am i right am i right
so if this sounds like something that
you'd be into you should check out
hellotushy.com
and you can get 10 percent off plus free
shipping right now
at hellotushi.comyang that's
hellotushi.com for 10 off
and free shipping i got a thank you note
about this product the other day made me
happy hello tushie.com they literally
have a 60-day risk-free happy butt
guarantee and a 12-month warranty so you
can literally use this thing in your
toilet
and return it that's how low risk this
is
and i promise you like cause i've loved
it it's also cut down space i have a
small apartment
and so i like actually one toilet paper
like package
takes up a ton of room so this doesn't
it's fantastic hellotushy.com
slashing
[Music]
marcus you and i share something very
deep um
you've done a more direct job than i
have significantly so
like i despair for
the
death of american entrepreneurship where
if you look at because i'm a numbers guy
particularly among young people like the
rate of small business formation has
plummeted over the last number of years
in most of the country more businesses
have been closing than opening
if you look at small business or or new
business formation among
younger generations uh it's
it's down more than 50 than it was in
previous generations
and you keep talking or you know if you
turn on cnbc frankly or a lot of these
other places
like you don't get that message you
don't get the message that small
businesses
are um are and this is even pre-coveted
like with kovid now you're like
accelerating
um the the elimination of a lot of these
businesses it's like a hyper
cleanse it's like a hyper cleanse right
now yeah it's heartbreaking
because you and i know what the what
went into that small business it's like
this person busting their tail for
you know years or even decades like
building that bar restaurant or flower
shop or hardware store or whatever it is
maybe that was what we were debating
about on social
i am a huge believer in the theory
behind small business
and i'm a huge believer in the idea of
taking chances on yourself
but i am also a huge believer that you
have to do the work
and you have to follow a process and you
have to be accountable for your behavior
and you have to know your numbers and
you have to
you have to execute and i have found
over the years
that i meet uh uh i meet the have and
the have-nots and that's not
uh what you typically would think it
would mean they haven't have nots or
they either have it or they don't and
when i say habit they understand that in
order to compete with a medium or large
size business
they have to execute at a higher level
and saying well i'm a small business and
i don't know my numbers because i don't
have the resources or i'm a small
business and i don't
have uh the the good processed in my
business because i don't have the
capital and i always tell small
businesses
that i hate to call small i just call
them local businesses
that you have to elevate and operate at
such a higher level
to even have a chance of surviving to
even have a chance at levering the
playing field and i
i don't want to feel sorry for you i
want to
motivate you to get it right well i love
meeting
people who run small businesses or local
businesses because that you know they
eat sleep and breathe it
and oftentimes like they're such
um energetic humans uh you know like
very likable um you know like
on this one so so that there are two
things that work that i think have
actually been very much in tension in
american life the last number of years
um so number one is i completely agree
with you that you got to know your your
numbers and your business
and execute at a high level like whether
you're the truck
uh the food truck all the way up to you
know in your case the public company i
mean it doesn't matter what your scale
is like you
you have to know um how you can make
money on like every
transaction or you know or um
who to hire and who who you have to get
rid of and things like that
um but there are these structural trends
in the economy and covid is the the
biggest example where i was
talking to a restaurateur who's an
excellent restaurateur
and the fact that those restaurants are
now um going to be shot
for a while has nothing to do with his
confidence as a restaurateur you know he
i mean he's very competent but
you know but you look at what's going on
with kovid he i mean he broke down the
numbers he was like look the fact is
uh you know like if i'm forced to space
out
the my patrons in my restaurant like
it's a 30
reduction most of my money came from
from booze
people aren't coming into my place to
like sit there and have leisurely drinks
anymore like if they're doing anything
they're ordering the lower margin
takeout
uh and and so when i do the math on it
like i'm better off staying closed
you know so um so
like it's that kind of trade-off so both
things are true it's like do people need
to be ass kickers and hold themselves
accountable 100 yes
and then like are there structural
problems right now that are making it so
that young people are having trouble
starting businesses and
like people who have been you know
putting their
blood sweat and tears into a business
are now forcing being forced to close
their doors like yeah that
that's true too i think it's the
multi-generational
family businesses where there is
um clearly the multi-generations working
there whether it's two generations or
three
that have built their whole livelihood
and their family's lineage
off of this one business that really are
the ones that scare me the most
you know a guy out of college our age
you know say we got out of college and
we wanted to start like a sports bar or
something
i'm not minimizing the importance of
that business
but it is different um when you have
multi-generations and you have kids yeah
and it's just a different business and
i've seen so many get taken out
and you know a solid business and and
this may be something to to talk about
but a solid business
prior to covid is usually one that will
make it through covet because they
understood
don't leverage too much have cash in
reserve
keep your your your personnel expenses
variable
those who are living on the edge with
lots of credit card debt taking money
out of their company
they didn't treat their customers right
they didn't treat their employees right
when things went bad that net
that most customers will provide or most
associates will provide that soft
landing doesn't exist and so when we
look at the number of businesses that
may
end up going away you have to really be
honest with yourself and say
there's a portion of them that quite
frankly
probably were going to go away anyway
and that doesn't mean in an extended
period of time like you sped up the
cycle
i i think there was a massive accelerant
of a lot of these trends um and
a lot of them i agree with you if you
stretched out the time horizon
we're heading in that direction uh so
you've
invested 75 million dollars directly
into these small businesses
and you know it's real because then you
came up essentially with like a
companion show
where you needed to find people that
would help operate some of these
businesses
which makes perfect sense if you've been
invested to become a partner
uh in in dozens of enterprises uh
like this must really be for the love
because like i'm sure
your account or financial advisor or
team is like hey marcus like there are a
lot easier ways to make money than this
actually i'll take it a step further
most people that i'm very close with
including my now spouse is vehemently
opposed to me doing what i do
because they believe without digging
deeper that it feels
reckless to them and it feels
irresponsible to them
my counter argument to them is that i
don't have any kids
i don't have any brothers and sisters um
and that
my connection to society in
in the us is through these small
business owners they are like extended
family
and so i really looked at this as a
giant social experiment and i said to
people look
at the end of the day i don't mind
paying taxes
and i don't my and i love to make money
and so if those are two things exist
i'm left with something and so if i
don't have
kids or lineage to leave the money to
and i can change
people's perspectives of themselves i
can change
other people's perspectives of how hard
it is to do this
or i can teach lessons in between
that's okay for me that's actually good
enough for me and
and i mean how much money does somebody
need i don't i don't like i don't
people don't need that much money well
the obvious question
given that you're a relative newlywed is
are kids like in
on the way no probably not because i've
made it
people ask me that all the time but the
life choices that i've made and this is
one of the hardest things for
entrepreneurs
is that to own your own business
requires sacrifice
and most people think before they buy
the business or before they start it
that it's going to be this glamorous
thing where they're going to be their
own boss and they're going to write
their own chat yeah it's not
all this is it's actually going to work
with the most risk with the least reward
and so if you really were if you were
running an ad campaign
of how of why not to open up a small
business the ad campaign would be easy
if you'd like to lose money and have a
lot of stress in your life and have
broken relationships
you can run the risk of starting a
business it'll probably happen
and for me i wanted to be that that
um that person that changes it and it
was funny because
we always get compared to shark tank
where the sort of two shows where people
invest in businesses and it was really
important to me to differentiate
ourselves from that show primarily
because
i wanted to know more i wanted to know
okay i saw a deal get done
tell me more tell me about the people
tell me about their motivation tell me
what's going to happen next
what about their employees who's making
the decisions and you know better than
most people
that that the reality of things are much
deeper than the surface much deeper yeah
and you're excellent at peeling the
onion back
and um i think more of us need to do
that there's more to this story like
paul harvey would say there's more to
the story
and that was really how the prophet was
born what's the rest of the story how
does it really work
and it doesn't always end well there's
not a giant move that bust movement
moment where everybody's happy and and
and cries
yeah you're i mean your stories are much
more real and human i think
um shark tank it's like you know it's
just like the room where the deal
happens i mean that like that that's
like
like only one component uh and i i found
that just about every small business
is essentially like a human story or a
family story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one side effect of running for president
is that you become a mattress
connoisseur
because we slept in airbnbs we slept in
cheap hotels we slept in nicer hotels
down the stretch thank you yangyang
and i'd say i consider myself someone
who like doesn't care that much
about a lot of things but i started to
really appreciate it if there was like a
good mattress a foot i became a little
bit of a mattress knob
and now that we're off the trail i only
sleep on a bed
of 10 mattresses piled high on top of
each other
and then if you put a p underneath i can
feel it because i'm a princess
now but if you're in the market for a
great mattress
go to helixsleep.com they give you one
of those
quizzes where they personalize the
mattress to you
how you sleep it's the number one best
overall mattress pick
of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired this is it this is the best of
breed
mattress that they send to you give you
that two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you with a mattress that will be
the best sleep of your life 10-year
warranty
100 night risk-free that's a little
weird to try a mattress for a hundred
nights and then be like now i don't like
it
but go to helixsleep.comyang
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.comyang that's helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com yang for up to 200
off
[Music]
you've launched a small business
learning center for anyone trying to
start a small business
that you're trying to help and you've
launched a 50 million dollar foundation
to help small businesses and families
call the lemonade foundation um i might
be missing
uh i mean i i guess you know that's just
a play in your name
like lemonis so you know
it um the reason i launched the learning
center is that one of the things that i
learned through my eight-year
journey with over 100 businesses on the
air
is that there's a common thread of what
they were missing
and they were missing a depth of
education and the education isn't one
plus one equals two or what's the
capital of the state of florida
it's what are the real things that
happen in a business from inventory
management to hr risk to
you know hundreds and hundreds of topics
and you know that as a business owner
that those things happen and so i wanted
to create a center
where people felt hey it's free
b people could do it in the privacy of
their own home and there are so many
folks who don't know the answer to
things but they're embarrassed to admit
they don't know it
um and i i'm one of those people
sometimes if you ask me a question i may
fake it
and i decided years ago that i wasn't
going to fake it i was going to say
can you explain that to me i don't know
it i don't understand that
and i realize that the key is it's very
powerful if you can acknowledge
ignorance it's very powerful
it's it makes the other person feel
i think more connected to you yeah
because you're saying like andrew i
don't understand how that works
and uh it really hit me one day i got a
call from jamie dimon
uh uh from you know from jp morgan i was
working on something my phone rang
uh on the other end of the line hi uh is
this marcus yes
uh hi this is jamie okay i didn't know
who it was
i'd like to just talk to you for a few
minutes you have a few minutes i'm kind
of in the middle of something um
but i would be glad because i might you
could find my cell phone on the internet
and i said i'd be glad to talk to you i
can't do it right now he said
well um you know i'm your banker and i
said
oh okay i'm sorry sir i i think you may
have me confused my banker is
i said this woman's name he goes no no
i'm that woman's boss
and he said this is jamie dimon i said
no seriously
who is this like i i'm really busy and
he said well listen i only called i got
mine
i got your phone number uh from steve
burke who is the chairman of nbc at the
time
who was on the board and he said i just
want to call and tell you that
um i know you think you're only helping
small business but you're really helping
people understand
the human psychology of business
and that is something that you can't
teach
in a classroom and uh i just wanted to
tell you that
and then maybe chase ended up becoming
like a six-year sponsor of the show
nice the point the point of that is i
think for me is
you would like what you do and what i do
all we're trying to do is just
educate inform inspire that's
it again you you've acted
in a way that's really unique
singular because you've walked the walk
for years at great personal cost not
just
in terms of financial resources but
really the most precious thing of all
which is like your time
energy and spirit i'm actually going to
to
explain to you what i did which was like
my my shot at the same problem
just because i i want to hear what you
think um so
i you and i graduated from college
around the same time i was not as
enterprising as you so i went to law
school
and then after i went to law school i
tried to start a business that did not
work out and then
ended up going through sort of the ups
and downs of entrepreneurship
and so years later after my company was
acquired
in 2009 and 2011 i started a non-profit
that tried to train the next generation
of entrepreneur and help startups grow
so the organization's called venture for
america i wanted to see what you hear
what you think of this
so the thought process was that they're
all of these
enterprising college graduates who want
to learn to become someone like you
but right now they go to jp morgan and
deloitte these big consulting and
finance shops to quote-unquote learn
about business
so what venture for america does venture
for america puts them through a boot
camp
of five weeks and then sends them to
work at early stage growth companies run
by entrepreneurs
in detroit cleveland baltimore new
orleans
birmingham and other cities around the
country so it's like a two-year national
entrepreneurship apprenticeship
fellowship and then at the end of two
years
if they want to start their own business
then we have investors in a seed fund to
put money
into them and so the goal was to try and
create like an
army of future use essentially
by sending them to work at these
organizations
so the way that you have like the
learning center to try and teach people
about these things
though our approach was we had that camp
but then we said look just go work at
the business for two years
at like these formative um 20s
you know because most of them are coming
out of college
wow i mean what an amazing idea and and
how long has the program been running
uh we started it in 2011 so it's nine
years in
um we have some real successes where
some of the alums have started
significant enterprises
uh you know at this point i think we're
responsible for something like maybe
um like a few thousand jobs like
depending upon how you
calculate it um i should put you in
touch with the the ceo but i i started
and ran that organization full time
uh for six and a half years and it was
only after i
realized that the pro the changes in our
economy were going to be much bigger and
hairier than anything i could counteract
with like my
army of uh entrepreneurs that i decided
to do the
inadvisable thing of running for
president
well you made a statement and i think it
was an appropriate statement to make
i think you gave a lot of people a lot
of hope and and
the idea of possibilities and
opportunity and i think that that
singular moment was a huge character
defining moment
the fact that you're giving young
entrepreneurs
a chance to work in the real world and
then
if they succeed and if they follow the
program
there's opportunity for them to do more
is really
i think at the center of what i believe
in which is i want to give you a hand up
but i'm not going to give you a handout
and you got to work for it and you got
to show me you're committed to it and
the way you show me you're committed to
it
is by going to work and following
through and i think that's amazing
how how can other people get involved in
the organization people like me
oh people like you jeez marcus we'll
roll out the red carpet i'll put you in
touch with the ceo
uh because you could speak at the
training camp um
you know you could mentor some of the
folks who are coming out uh
you know you could do you could i mean
invest in in some of the
the growth businesses uh you'd love it
it's essentially an army of aspiring use
and uh and to me the problem is that
like if you're an aspiring you i mean
you and i both had like
you know frankly like stumbles in our
20s because like you're just trying to
figure it out and like
and it's a very isolating circumference
we had stumbles in our 40s i think
yesterday yeah you stumbled the whole
time it's true
you know and and i'm sure in your case
too you eventually have like a few
uh people that you connect with on like
a real human level
um that understand you and what drives
you that's the most beautiful thing
about venture for america marcus is
these young people
become so close to each other uh that
like
imagine having that kinship early on
where instead of people just thinking
you're crazy there are at least a few
other crazy people like you
that are like yeah do that there's a
number of organizations out there
that don't do a similar thing in
practice
but in terms of principle of that
camaraderie it's like a ypo type
organization where these young folks are
sort of
part of the fraternity of young
entrepreneurs and there's something that
those lifelong relationships can never
be fractured i mean what you've done is
incredible um and i can sense you and i
saw the same
need and then you know we went after it
in different ways
uh like uh so it's that's one reason why
i'm such an admirer of yours is like i
understand the spirit
uh and and the spirit of what drives you
the spirit of
um of helping people become stronger
versions of themselves through this
process of entrepreneurship in many ways
because like the business of the
business but really it's about the
people
like it it's it's so vital in american
life and we don't talk about it enough
like you're you're one of the primary
champions that exists
of this uh and like
it used to be much more built into
american life uh but
now it's less so um i i think that's one
reason why
andrew why is that that i mean there are
a few very very big reasons
uh you know if someone asks me like i
say a lot of it is that we're in the
midst of the most extreme winner take
all economy in the history of the world
where
when you and i were coming out of
college there was no amazon like now
what's amazon amazon's like a
like one to two trillion dollar company
that you know just like hoover's up
commerce right
in the left like a generation ago if
someone were to want to start a hardware
store you might think that's a good idea
and then eventually you know like the
the big box retailers made that a bad
idea and then i liken it the big box
retailers were like tanks that came to
town and the mom and pop businesses were
like oh no there's a tank
um and amazon's like a spaceship
so if you're like these small business
owners you look up and you're like how
the hell do i compete with a spaceship
now you know like the spaceship doesn't
even need to make money in a given
quarter the spaceship has unlimited
capital unlimited data like so
um so so that's one big reason why it's
harder
uh you know for young people it's that
the college education that you and i
received in the 90s got two and a half
times more pricey
at some point uh and so you have these
young kids coming out
who now have you know life-changing debt
in a way that
like for you and me back in the 90s it
was plausible that we could quote
unquote work our way through school
you could actually like make enough
money to maybe pay for your school
but that was back when college cost uh
you know 20 to 25 grand a year and not
60 grand a year and like
you know it's like can a kid like you
know work their way through 60 grand a
year it's like less likely
and then their choices get constrained
like a lot of the
community financial institutions that
used to exist got gobbled up by
you know like the jp morgans of the
world where like the consolidation
you see in retail for amazon has
happened in financial services for sure
it happens in tech for sure like like
there are a lot of like the biggest
industries that have become
consolidated around like a few winners
um
you know media and journalism is another
like 2000 local newspaper is gone so if
you're like a local journalist like you
know
like that that's gone and so you you
have a shot if you go to new york and
work for
um for nbc or like one of those like you
know
those outlets persist um so there's
something
uh that's been lost and people like you
and i are looking at it and we've sensed
it
and then we're like huh like we and and
what gets lost too
is that process that makes those people
into the people they aspired to be
like in in some ways the people that you
and i have become
uh they'll wear kind of an earlier
generation than a lot of them
yeah it um i worry about where
we go from here and i
uh along with you feel like it's time to
double down
on the young people because i don't know
what 10 years
20 years looks like if they become
disenchanted
or disillusioned or suppressed and so
when when we started this foundation
this 50 million dollar foundation
it was exclusively uh to provide
financial grants loans and
equity investments to underserved
communities and underserved individuals
and people have said incredible
yeah you're just you're just trying to
help poor people
and i said no i'm actually not trying to
help any specific
class of people other than those who
have not been given the same
opportunities that i was given
period and so we don't need to debate it
because it's my money
it kind of doesn't matter what you think
and so
it's not like i'm using your money or
the government's money this is what i
believe in there are women
uh and people of color who haven't been
given the same opportunity
by the way when they take my money i'm
going to put them through the same paces
the same way i just want people to feel
like if they had an opportunity
what would they do with it if they fail
it's no different than people that are
males or people that are not of color
and so i just i worry about them and i
worry about
our our societal disregard or lack of
acknowledgement
people like to talk about it um and say
we should start a fund and you watch a
lot of these big companies
well we're we're donating a certain
amount of money to this cause it's like
it's not a cause
it's not a charity these people are not
um
they're not they're not unfortunately
they're not um
you know um uh handicapped they're not
disabled
they're just uh social and economically
disabled and i want to try to fix that
am i going to fix it
i probably won't am i going to try for
damn sure
you're going to fix it you're going to
fix it for um
a certain number of people and that in
itself is incredible
like if it's just for one then i'm okay
exactly
you know like like i ran an education
company that served
thousands of people and i said it's like
you know if you want to teach a thousand
people
teach one person then do it a thousand
times you know like
the same with what you're trying to do
if you're trying to remedy these
inequities
do it for one person and then do it
again and then they'll teach other
people
yeah i mean that that's the way change
occurs uh and
i i love what you said too it's like
look like it's my money i'm gonna do
what i want like that there's so
few people that have made it to your uh
your stature uh that do what you do
marcus you really are one of a kind
uh i'm so glad that we connected and
i'm i'm thrilled to um to support
anything you do and to champion your
work
because we need more people like you and
i i guarantee that you're going to
create
other people that are like yourself
through your work uh because you're
going around identi i mean it's it's
hard to
have another you um but it's the the
same kind of thing i experienced with
venture for america
i don't want another me there's enough
me creating enough chaos and enough
noise and enough frustration
one is enough and then we're good but
andrew i thank you so much my friend
i really appreciate the chat i
appreciate the heck out of you
so what can people look out for you have
a new podcast coming out in a new series
so they can just go on to marcus
lemonis.com where the learning center
the foundation
and the podcast all are i wanted to
simplify it make it easy
and then we're back with uh the profit
uh first of the year 2021 so we're
excited
marcus limonas.com thank you marcus
appreciate the heck out of you
happy holidays youtube brother bye-bye
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you